the Joe Rogan experience that shows you
how [ __ ] tough you write a favor it
was ridiculous - he's back it's not just
that - how about the fight when we
fought Mike Brown and he broke both his
hands yeah
broke both his [ __ ] hands so he's
throwing elbows and kicks and he's
trying to keep this guy off him yeah
dude and he's back as well hey I want to
see him again pseudo dude I want to see
you too I mean it came close it seemed
like this is almost something that
really could happen because like when he
knocked out Ricky Simone and everybody
was like what yeah quick what this is
crazy your eye comes back he's starching
people and good fighters knocks out a
good fighter a young up-and-coming
talented kid just catches him perfect
and like a mere I have favors in the
hunt
yeah and then everybody loves him and so
he starts talking [ __ ] - who don't so
who don't starts talking [ __ ] to him me
like wow yeah but first who dough has to
fight Valentina Shevchenko and Amanda
Nunez apparently she's new shirt is an
inter-gender champion shirt yes yes
goat is this really love oh I love it
Henry I'm in your corner you keep this
out no more cake he's got people excited
about flyweight man yeah but dude stuff
I love it as well be pro wrestling look
at this everybody's in on it let me see
it look at that into gender world
champion it's all in gold on a black
shirt god bless you Henry cejudo god
bless you that's terrible he's [ __ ]
and caught me in his way he's arguably
if he's not the most accomplished MMA
fighter in history he's the most
accomplished combat sports athlete
that's that's undeniable to show that's
undeniable impetus medalist and to
division world champion he can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want let him wear
that shirt let him go crazy you'd let
him do whatever he wants that's Henry
cejudo he does with everyone I think the
girls are all in on it
and I think it helps everybody because
everybody's getting pumped up about it
it's a joke a man at Nunez thinks it's a
joke she posed with them the Valentina
Shevchenko's and at those fights in tho
they would both [ __ ] him up - no I'm
just kidding
they you know you really don't want to
see 135-pound man ever fight amanda
Nunez you know you don't want to see it
you don't to see it but I'll see Amanda
Nunez fight anybody else and I'll see
Valentina Shevchenko fighting anybody
else I mean it would be it would be
horrible if you saw a men's world
champion fight of women's world champion
and he [ __ ] her up that would be
terrible beautiful I would never ever
want to see that I was offered a fight
against you main to random e1 she's hot
in a scary way
she's scary in a scary way yeah you know
I mean that with all due confidence and
all due respect rather I'm a giant fan
of her so I think she's me I had a
conversation with dream killer Bolanos
you know Gaston Bolanos from Muay Thai
and now he fights yep he's fighting in
Bellator we were talking about her and
he he said I think she has the best
fight IQ of anybody like maybe better
than anybody in the sport man or woman
and I was like I can't argue it no well
I mean you watched that last fight
against Liz Carmouche and I know a lot
of people complained that it was a you
know it was a slow fight but and this is
something I realized actually during
that fight sometimes you need to see the
whole octagon to really appreciate
what's going on you know sometimes you
need to see like an elevated shot of the
whole space because her ability to
control that space with the the threat
of doing something and their ability to
cut people off what is she doing here
super well she's breaking down a
Superman oh yeah she's hot in a scary
way in a Bond villain kind of yeah yeah
well you like please she throws her
spinning backfist differently as well
which i think is a good reason for
because most people are throwing their
spinning backfist with their arms
straight and then breaking the forearm
right was when she throws she's throwing
it with her elbow down which means that
if she hits with the forearm is hitting
both bones interesting yes I think is
busted that's the reason she does it
you might the right I mean it makes
sense